the Herschel Walker story is becoming
dare I say completely kafka-esque so
earlier this week the story came out
of a woman saying Herschel Walker claims
to be against abortion he says abortion
is murder in his Senate candidacy in
Georgia but he urged me to get an
abortion when he impregnated me and he
paid for the abortion and after that
story came out Herschel Walker denied
even knowing who the woman is saying he
doesn't know saying he definitely didn't
pay for anybody's abortion and uh that
that's part of why the story is made up
because he doesn't even know the woman
it turns out based on new reporting from
The Daily Beast that the woman in
question is someone that is actually
already the mother of another one of her
Herschel Walker's children and this just
blows the story wide wide open it is an
unbelievable new development in the
story
and I later we're going to play Bill
O'Reilly's advice to Herschel Walker and
to some degree Bill O'Reilly's advice is
making sense which is he may just want
to come clean on this she had an
abortion with Herschel Walker reads The
Daily Beast headline she also had a
child with him Herschel Walker has
claimed he has no idea who the woman
could be here is why that is surprising
and Roger sullenberger for The Daily
Beast writes there's a good reason the
woman finds the defense that Walker
doesn't know who she is highly doubtful
she is the mother of one of his children
folks the story is falling apart
the article writes when the woman first
told The Daily Beast or story we agreed
not to reveal certain details about her
identity over concerns for safety and
privacy then Walker categorically denied
the story said he didn't know who was
making the allegation Wednesday morning
Fox host Brian Kilmeade asked Walker did
you figure out the woman's identity not
at all Walker replies and that's what I
hope everyone can see it's sort of like
everyone is anonymous or everyone is
leaking and they want you to confess to
something you have no clue about Walker
called it a desperate attack and on and
on and on the anonymous woman said the
defense sounded ridiculous sure I was
stunned she said but I guess it also
doesn't shock me that maybe there are
just so many of us he truly doesn't
remember but then again if he really
forgot about it that says something too
the woman told The Daily Beast her Chief
concern with revealing her name was
because she is the mother of Walkers one
of Walker's own children and she wanted
to protect her family's privacy
Walker has publicly acknowledged the
child as his own and the woman proved
she is the child's mother and provided
evidence of a long-term relationship
with Walker
it's one of the mothers of one of his
children remember that Walker went on
the Hannity program and answered about
whether he knows the woman in This Way
start with The Daily Beast Herschel I
mean serious accusations that in 2009
that you paid for an abortion first
question do you know the woman that is
making this allegation
I have no idea no idea but it is a
flight out lie yeah he has no idea a new
interview with Hugh Hewitt where again
he says he doesn't know who the woman is
so just to put a bow on it do you have
any idea who this alleged former lover
of yours is who says you paid for an
abortion on father to child any idea
whatsoever I have no idea at all and
that's the problem is you know uh when
they said I had the kids that I was
hiding a lot of people don't know that
this same reporter found out that this
was not true never wrote a retraction
never said anything they just let it go
it went on and that is of course untrue
Roger sullenberger didn't write a
retraction because the story is accurate
that he originally wrote about Walker's
kid and
um Walker actually acknowledged that as
well
unbelievable implosion it is not only a
woman who was impregnated but then had
an abortion at Walker's request she also
birthed one of Walker's kids and 24 more
hours is probably all that this story
has given that the pressure is really
mounting on Herschel Walker I have a
really tough time finding dress shirts I
like they're either uncomfortable or
they're tight or they're loose or hot or
itchy and that's why it's been so great
to discover the commuter shirts made by
our fantastic sponsor Rhone rhone's
commuter shirt is a reinvention of the
men's dress shirt it's the most
comfortable dress shirt I've worn Roan's
comfortable four-way stretch fabric
provides the breathability and the
flexibility that leaves you free to
enjoy what life throws your way could be
a long day at work could be brunch with
the family you're just going to be
comfortable and that's so important with
rhone's wrinkle release technology the
wrinkles disappear as you stretch and
wear the shirt which is very convenient
and Rhone is 100 machine washable so you
can skip the dry cleaning altogether
I've had a great experience with Rhone
the shirts are appropriate if you want
to look nice or somewhat formal
I rarely need to and they're just as
good as a comfortable t-shirt when you
want to relax or just move around in it
go to rhone.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman to get 20 off the most
comfortable shirt you'll ever own the
link is down below